well welcome everybody to the data
science hangout
um i know that most of you have all been
here before so welcome back
but for anyone who's just joining this
is an open space for current and
aspiring data science leaders
everybody across the data science
community
to connect and chat about some of the
more human centric questions around data
science leadership
and so we really want to create this
space where everybody can participate
and we can hear from everyone
so there's a few different ways that you
can jump in and ask questions
you could just unmute yourself and ask
questions live
you could put questions in the chat
and we also have a slido link which
tyler will share in a moment here where
you could ask anonymous questions too
also if you put a question in the zoom
chat and
you want me to read it out loud instead
of you calling on you you could also put
a little star at the end of it
and i'll know to just read that out loud
but just wanted to make a quick note
that the session will be recorded and
shared up to youtube
as well for anybody who missed it
but with that i'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host for today nate
kratzer who's data science manager at
brown foreman
and nate i'd love to just have you
introduce yourself and maybe share a
little bit about the work that you do on
your team today
great thanks rachel and thanks to
everyone for for being here looking
forward to you know getting to talk to
all of you for this lunch hour or at
least lunch hour where i'm located some
of you may be joining from other time
zones um so i'm nate i'm a data science
manager
at brown foreman uh brown foreign is the
company that owns jack daniels woodford
reserve and several other liquor and
spirits brands
so i work
with two different teams one of them is
a team that works on actually making the
liquor which
lots of fun stuff come comes out of that
we get to talk about how to produce the
barrels of just
all sorts of actual engineering
processes that team largely uses uh
python tableau and
sql
to get their their job done though they
are also you know heavy users of the r
studio projects within uh
within the python framework i also work
with a team
that does pricing and i came out of that
team doing a lot of
pricing work estimating price
elasticities that team largely builds
stuff in
r
and also uses equal and and tableau as
well
and is you know
mainly concerned with what happens when
we change the prices on the shelves and
how does that affect sales and profit
and everything
awesome
thanks nate
um so while we're waiting for some
questions to come in from the audience
i'd love to just ask you
maybe what's something that you're most
excited about lately
with regards to data science
i'm excited about the way data science
is slowly growing into our organization
i think um
you know when i
when i started at brownforum which was
like four years ago we had
three data scientists and it was sort of
just this side project that the
organization was was vaguely considering
someone said you should put some money
into data science and
there were some analysts already there
who were interested and so they they
formed this very small data science team
i was
i think maybe the second person hired
from the outside that wasn't just like a
convert from within
um
and now
it's grown and we've also grown in a way
of having data scientists embedded in in
other parts of the organization
um
and so seeing that there
there's an actual effect from all of
this work and that what started as sort
of a
well let's just try it this is a thing
we sort of are hearing about there's
some hype to
okay yeah there are actual decisions
being made off of you know a bunch of
the products that the the data science
team has built
that's awesome
what are some of the i'm just curious
what are some of the decisions that have
been made or big impacts to the business
from data science
yeah so
um they vary from from things that are
more more visible to to you all like
what what sizes
should we sell on shelves you know like
we've looked at things like how much
difference does it does it make
um
pricing how often we should promote etc
but there's also stuff we do on the the
back end a lot like we've looked at
one of my favorite things to do is to
get to actually run experiments in
production and our part of this is
normally people asking like okay if we
want to experiment with a different
shape of bourbon barrel that will hold a
bit more
how many do we need to test to make sure
that it doesn't have a negative yield
impact
um and that we're still
you know getting the same amount and
then what impact might this have on
color
you know how can we we track all of
those those things on the back end
cool so did you end up changing the
barrel size or shape
you know that that came to mind because
i was recently asked about like how many
we need i don't have the results yeah
yet i just figured out literally how
many like of the larger barrels we need
to make in order to test it so
that's cool step i see you just put a
question into the chat if you want to
ask live
yeah sure um
as a recurring question i'm very curious
about um
obviously we can't do the data science
or analysis without data so i'm just
curious where where you guys generally
get your data from and what processes
you guys have for kind of ingesting and
prepping it so that you can kind of do
the magic
yeah so there's there's a lot of
different sources that we could talk
through so
i'll talk about
a few so the the pricing work that i've
spent the most time with is honestly
bought from nielsen within the united
states
liquor has a three-tail three-tiered
system so we sell to a distributor who
sells to a retailer who sells to a
customer
so like i i don't have any direct
customer data right like i have no idea
who's buying what um so we get some
aggregated
data from nielsen which has bought it
from those endpoint retailers in terms
of how much they sold and at what price
um and they get a lot of it from from
retailer scans and then you know sell
that back to us
um we have a data engineering team so
the process there looks roughly along
the lines of nielsen sends a data extra
extract in some sort form of text file
the engineering team ingested it
they do a few joins for us ahead of time
expose it to us on a sql server
and then we pull it down um
you know like we we've got an r package
that that works on this so we've got a
script that essentially calls
calls the functions we've written
through pulling it from sql
cleaning the data transforming it
running the model and then post model we
also prep the data a bit
before for things we want to do with the
model coefficients so that we're not
just saying oh your price elasti is this
but we're also breaking down how it
matters we also get
a lot of data internally more on the
production side and that's also
transformed rapidly 10 years ago our
source of data would have been a
clipboard that someone was riding on
by hand
actually even five years ago that that
would have been the case some places
um
so one of the things that and that team
is is very heavily they wind up doing a
lot of data engineering a lot of
prepping for
um how do we even get and collect this
data in the first place um
we have
uh we've had issues that we've we've
tried to deal with like
we want to know how big each barrel is
so we had a machine that you know
rotates the barrel and in theory
measures it with lasers but occasionally
this gets miscalibrated because i don't
know if someone hits it with a forklift
or just machines go out of calibration
over time and then we have to figure out
like what what is the offset for this
what
what should it be so there's
that end is both
i mean depending on your perspective i
think it's really fun and that we get to
work with everything like
what are the sensors in the warehouse
where are they located temperature
humidity like all sorts of a fun direct
data collection but also it means
there's a lot of data engineering for
that team
thinking about even five years ago
people using clipboards and and tracking
the data that way i see um arafat had a
question in the chat
and said curious to know was there any
particular project that helped to get
buy-in from top management to expand
to the data science route
yeah so i think the first one
was actually the the pricing and the
reason for this is
the
the two types of projects that i think
have have gotten the most by and have so
far been ones that directly replaced
other things and therefore it's easier
to see
what they're doing
and so they either replace an excel
process
you know it used to be the case that we
might have an analyst spend a week
figuring out a price elasticity for one
model
or for one market
and now like once we have the process in
place you know we're using the same
model
in about 20 different countries and each
country has multiple markets within it
etc so like just the massive speed up of
doing the same work uh with more
accuracy but also with with more speed
and then when we've been able to replace
consultants
with with data that it used to be the
case we would pay an outside analysis
firm to do the analysis
um instead of internally setting that up
i think
as i was talking through that there's
there's one third case that i forgot to
mention
that's possibly most relevant here
our production team when they were first
introduced to shiny apps
because they've been trying to manage
everything and and sort of slowly going
digital through
going largely from pen and paper to like
google sheets occasionally
but it was very easy for one of our
first data scientists in production
to just spin up a shiny app that would
show them
the things they needed
because it could pull in data from
multiple sources
it could do all the formatting within
the app it could give them a single
place to go
so there was a
pretty early transition i think within
production to like shiny just proved out
its value almost immediately in terms of
especially for the r d team
the things they could look at and
you know just some so like i think one
of the very first shiny apps we deployed
was just something where
um they wanted to run pca analysis on
some chemical results and we were just
like okay here's the thing where you can
upload your csv and then all of it will
be run and you'll get all the charts you
want right away
right and that just instantly saves
hours of people's time so that got a lot
of buy-in as well
that's great
somebody had just asked me
yesterday
how to calculate the roi
on switching over to data science tools
and
they were just asking me if i had
examples from different customers
but i feel like i never hear things in
terms of
like dollar amounts of this is the exact
roi and that's so hard to calculate
and i was just curious if you
had done that at all like do you think
of what the consultant's hourly cost was
or what it cost in excel
yeah so most formally we have a project
that tracks us through a shiny app of
course in production but it tracks
specifically
um process improvement
so that's that's one that that's easier
to demonstrate like if we run an
experiment and it changes a process or
it allows us to increase the the yield
coming out of our mills um i should say
i said brown forum is a liquor company
we also own the cooperage that makes the
barrels and we also like buy the wood
directly so like that whole barrel
making processes
is within our scope and when you're
starting to look at those also warehouse
conditions so
climate change has reduced bourbon
yields um essentially like hotter
conditions tend to mean we yield less
bourbon because more of it evaporates
while it's sitting in the barrels
you know so we've looked at things like
how do we get back to
to that normal state so when you can put
it in yield terms
we don't have
an overall roi um we have
you know like occasionally we get
estimates of like what our work would
have cost if it went through a
consultant but we've never actually like
tried to add
all of that up
yeah i
i don't often see you but they were they
were asking me for it so i was like
looking through like meetups and other
recordings trying to see if if people
had mentioned that um i see steve had
asked on slido out of interest what are
the main computing platforms that you
use
yeah so
you're just looking for like where we
actually do do the math we have um
we have our studio workbench on a fairly
giant
server which is is where we uh
where we do our development we are
transitioning to
also using a connect server for some of
the stuff that's that's in production
because it will allow us to automate and
also it will allow us to separate
production from dev
um but maybe i should back up a second
and just explain our our general
tool set um so
we
we have our studio workbench where all
of us can can log in
you know it's set up on a linux server
with like a terabyte of ram we have
nothing in the cloud we do everything
in-house so we need a fairly large
server to accommodate all data
scientists and the
any of the work we could perform
and generally that process will be we
have a
a sql database a lot of stuffs in
cloudera although production has some of
their own sql servers that i think are
microsoft sql servers still
and we'll wind up you know connecting
through odbc
pulling in our data
running the calculations in either r or
python
and then we will push them back to a
database
and then from that
so we'll have our own section of the
database that we run as an advanced
analytics team
and then we will build the front end app
in either shiny or tableau off of that
transformed data
i see arafat theatre just asked another
question um
that yeah
you uh mentioned i should read live
so if possible could you please shed
some more light on the kind of post
model work that you perform
sure so
you know for
for our price elasticities
like we we build a model of
the entire market so it's it's not just
price it's also distribution how many
stores is it in how is the category it
performs in like whiskey doing
um how is the overall spirits market
doing etc
and you know one of the things we do is
we go back
through the past year and we say
okay if we compare the last
13 weeks of sales
to the same 13 week period a year ago
and we apply our price elasticity to the
actual pricing difference that we
observed historically what's the impact
in actual case volume
so we're we're presenting our users with
something where they can say oh if i'm
looking at like this most recently
rolled up to account for some noise but
if i'm looking at what's happening now
not just what was the price elasticity
but how did that actually impact me
based on what was happening in prices at
the market
um
and we've also you know rolled out
something where
you know using shiny users can upload
like this is my pricing plan for next
year
what would your model predict is going
to happen
right um so the ideas that were
really as much as possible
giving them that part of that is because
users would try to do these with the
do these things with the price
elasticity coefficients on their own
and not only does that take a lot more
time if a bunch of different people are
you know repeatedly doing the same math
in different excel sheets but it also
was pretty air prone um and people did
not always understand the model there
there are good reasons to you know use
the entire model
as a whole and not just look at like
what would happen if i changed price but
actually enter a plan for you know
price competitors price whiskey segments
etc
thank you
i was thinking about what you said of
how you were one of the first data
scientists of the team onboarded from
external uh externally but now you have
about 14 data scientists
so wondering what that growth looked
like and how you scale data science out
across the team
yeah um
so i mentioned initially
the team came in so i think data science
and and r also came to brown foreman
from a financial analyst and someone in
the production team at about the same
time and they were completely separate
working independently
and then
you know we got
a few more
a bit more interest um in that initial
pricing
pricing work within finance
um i was involved in the r user group in
louisville and i met met someone who was
doing that work who had you know started
in finance and internally was
sort of the catalyst there so
wound up
on that team
which slowly expanded
some of the expansion was combining with
other teams that were already interested
we had a team that was doing a bit more
visualization work
and ultimately combined with them to get
like this core group of six and then a
big part of the expansion
um
was getting spoke rules so we run on a
model where there is there's a hub of
core data scientists and they are they
are just data scientists they report
into our advanced analytics team
but we also have folks who are say part
of our production team part of our us
commercial analytics team part of our
australia pricing team
you know um wherever there are
managers who who want to have
folks doing data science but also
directly reporting to their team so in
those cases what they get is they get to
set the agenda really in the projects
that are worked on
[Music]
but what they're provided with is
we make sure that they have access to
you know one the tech stack but also to
all of the data scientists in the hub so
that they're not just this isolated
person working alone
recreating the wheel
every time um
and that
that is a pretty big source of growth
because it is
taking existing spots
and
and making them the
third source i'd say is
we've been fairly successful with
year-long internship programs
and we have three or four folks who have
joined that way where we've created new
positions after they've done a year-long
internship
that's cool
i see there's a quite a few questions
coming through on on slido as well and
zach i see you just put a question into
the chat as well can i pass the mic over
to you to have you asked that one
yep
yep sure
so i was just wondering
so if
um i'm only a data analyst at my own uh
and i work for in a local government as
you probably tell i'm british and you
got american citizens slightly different
if i was just wondering how much of your
role is you going outside of your team
saying this is where you can improve
and trying to get them and persuade them
to make that improvement and verse how
much of that is them going we've got a
problem here
uh nate and his team
have solved a problem for someone else
they can probably help solve our problem
and then go to you
yeah so initially
when we first like formed an advanced
analytics data science team
there was a bit of saying hey this is
stuff we can do please please come to us
with with problems like that um and and
that was
our director at the time at the time i
was a senior data scientist not really
as involved with like soliciting work
from the rest of the organization
um and now we're we're at a point where
we have enough work without soliciting
it from the rest of the organization
um
where
there are there are definitely times
where i think it would be nice if if the
rest of the organization would do things
in more of the data science way of
course but like
we have enough people who want our help
that i'm not going to like push data
science on people who don't want our
help yet
so
we've been pretty much able to just work
with with the problems that uh that
people have we've also
so i i guess the one exception to that
perhaps is we've been working on
adoption
uh so
you know like within pricing there's
there's a lot of support from
corporate and for some of the high level
folks but then you get into the question
of well what if we're reaching out to
salespeople on the ground and to some of
the smaller countries smaller markets
doing some trainings there
i mean that's largely like again our our
partners who actually do pricing
reaching out to those other folks but we
have been trying to focus a lot of our
tools on adoption so
that comes both in the occasional
training meeting but also documentation
usability of tools
most of our revisions are focused not
now on adding new features but on making
existing features clearer making it
easier for end users to work with
me i see there's two questions that are
kind of similar
around shiny and tableau
so one said you've mentioned shiny and
tableau for your team
what goes into deciding when to use
which
and then i
see that ian also added
does it have to do with end user or
functionality for example
yeah so
it has to do with with a lot of those
things um
so i mean one of the first criteria of
course is if it's not something you can
do in tableau then we're going to use
shiny for it and then there's no
decision
um
another one that that sort of shortcuts
it is we think about who
not necessarily at the end user is but
the end maintainer
and so the reason the end user matters
less to us
is we have a
reasonably consistent sort of design
across shiny and tableau like folks
generally know we're going to have some
filters on the left we're going to have
a nice header telling you what it does
it's going to incorporate a little bit
of our branding and then we're going to
have
some graphs you know in the main panel
that react to the filters on the side
so we've never really had trouble with
users being confused anymore by by shiny
or tableau
and then we have a corporate center that
you know links dashboards and of course
you can also just send people links
directly
so it hasn't really been a problem for
end users
where it does matter is sometimes we
as a team are responsible for initially
building dashboards that we want other
folks in the business to maintain
and if we want someone else to maintain
it then we're a lot more likely to use
tableau
you know of our team of
you know 14 data scientists we probably
have five that are pretty good at
building shiny apps and can build and
maintain shiny apps but like that's it
for the entire organization
you know whereas we probably have about
100 folks who can at least build basic
tableau apps now
you know of those some are are much more
advanced and can build much more complex
things
but
just the
not the user of the dashboard but the
user in terms of the uh
the people maintaining dashboards
there's a much bigger base for tableau
and so that that can come into
consideration
um
the functionality has has probably been
the the biggest thing
um
so using shiny
you know you get
you get version control you get
the ability to be a lot more flexible
with your data and your setup you get
the fact that you can really go end to
end within a shiny app so in many cases
it's a lot faster
um
i can often if it's you know like if
it's a small enough data transformation
you know i can just work within r the
whole time quickly build a shiny app
look at my results right away i don't
have to wait for this step of even like
oh i'm going to output this even to a
csv or to a database and then run
tableau on top of it
so
there's
there's i suppose it's
a bit less of a consideration but still
i think a relevant consideration of like
what does the person building the
dashboard want to use and and what are
they fastest at um
you know tableau can make some data
transformations much more difficult than
if you're working in our python like it
is set up as a visualization tool
and
i i think tableau is in fact an
excellent visualization tool the
problems i observe in organizations are
when they try to push tools too far
outside of what they're designed for
um
and and so like our our prominent you
know our most prominent shining apps
where we just couldn't do it in tableau
is our forecasting work where we want
users to be able to interact with the
forecast and like set some of the
parameters and then we're going to run
the forecast
in the background
and then while some of our pricing stuff
is is in tableau you know some of it
where like if we want users to be able
to upload any sort of data and then
interact with models and so forth that's
all stuff that's going to wind up being
in shiny
um we just have a lot of additional
flexibility that way
would you be able to just for my
understanding to be able to give an
example of
what's something that
would need to be a shiny app because of
the model or what's like an exact
example versus something that would be
in tableau the two biggest ones i've
seen are
needing uh users to upload data
uh you know like we tried something with
some financial gaming in tableau where
people had to like enter by hand into
input boxes just like everything they
wanted and it just didn't get used
because it's a pain to enter data that
way
you know like whereas we've been able to
give them
uh in a shiny app like here you can
download last year's data as a default
change the things you want to change
upload it and see what our model says
the other one is is
connecting directly to outside apis
tableau probably has some of this but
our institutional tableau we can't add
tableau extensions so we really are just
dealing with like base tableau so like
we wanted to pull google trends into a
dashboard and and this is easy enough in
r there's a package for it we pull it in
we make some nice graphs and that's
something we just couldn't do in tableau
thank you yeah i think it's helpful to
just understand like because both are
great tools but understanding when you
would use one versus when you use the
other
and being able to communicate that
out to the team too
yeah and i mean the more calculations in
general you try to put into tableau the
harder it gets to use and maintain the
workbook you know like when people have
to use especially other people's tableau
workbooks
going back through it and like
unlayering and figuring out the
dependencies and so forth
of you know which calculation relies on
which other three calculations um
and what is the actual math here
becomes
fairly tricky like it's not the best
tool for all of your data manipulations
even though it can do some of them
thank you
laura i see you asked a great question
about how they're using data science
today um would you want to ask that one
live
yeah um
hi nate i i find this talk super
interesting i actually uh used to work
for
um irish distillers so i was working on
all the irish whiskeys back in ireland
and in the marketing area and i kind of
noticed that they were really trying to
make a big effort to bring in
and ai and ml particularly around
our packaging and i was just wondering
does either your teams do anything in
the marketing and advertising space in
relation to data science and analytics
yeah so hopefully i won't get myself in
too much trouble with my answer here um
so
i i have talked to marketing in
analytics and the truth is usually when
they come to me with a question of like
can you tell us what was the effect of
this marketing campaign my answer is no
i can't because every time i've tried
you know i don't just say no upfront i'm
like okay what data do we have let's
take a look etc but my answer does wind
up being
no there's not enough um
you know the short-term effects are
usually too small to capture the
long-term effects well there's just too
much going on with with the long term um
but i also think it's it's interesting
that you brought up you know where they
they want to go with with ai machine
learning since that's
not at all really where i'm pushing them
i'm pushing them to run experiments um
i think they should do a b testing i do
not think
you know like adding ai or ml
is is going to you know fundamentally
solve the problems we have of not having
good data
having too many things going on at once
um
like yes you're going to get some sort
of pattern
um
but you know fundamentally i think in
order to to actually evaluate marketing
you need to collect better data and you
need to actually be intentional about
causal inference and the easiest way to
do this is going to be
some sort of baby testing
i'll actually say more broadly while
ai and machine learning gets a lot of
hype
um there's
there's i know the common joke that like
80 of the time like the business just
needs a sql query with a group by but
like the other 20 of the time they need
something more advanced i think what
they need is causal influence
right like most of the time the business
is not
and this does vary um but at least in my
line of work like most of the time the
business for me wants to know you know
did my campaign cause something to
happen did the price change cause
something to happen
there are businesses i know where like
the prediction is is fine
like you know is this part going to wear
out in so many years like there's some
stuff and obviously like if you're
dealing with uh image data or
you know text and so forth like ai and
machine learning is a huge revelation
there
but for a lot of your day-to-day
business questions you need data to be
better organized you need research
design
and you need some understanding of
causal inference
that's a great question laura i had a
follow-up
on that too so if if that is what you
need but you don't have that today like
how do you
communicate that to the team or kind of
teach them maybe what data they should
have
yeah so
we've we've been working on that
actually with with marketing and
analytics um and a lot of this is
internal education and we'll we'll see
how well it works we're moving a little
at a time
you know our our basic pitch has been to
first of all just explain what a b
testing is to folks who aren't familiar
um i think it tends to be a good
entryway
to understanding research design because
as research designs go it's on the
simpler end we're going to have two
groups we're going to compare them
you're going to need us to help you set
up the groups that that i also will say
you need to stress
because there have been occasions in the
past where where folks did think they
were doing some sort of tests
and what they did was they said we're
going to run a huge media campaign in
the markets that are performing best
right now and not in the other ones and
you know they were doing this for
strategic reasons and it makes sense
perhaps as a strategy but it also
completely invalidates any sort of like
test if you're you're shifting your
your funding based on which markets are
performing well and not
not as a way to test the actual effect
of of expenditures and then we've also
been trying to get them to just just
start small and on things that are are
less threatening um so
you know any sort of test that could
result in funding being cut there's
always going to be pushback on that
right
you know like right now they're they're
getting the funding they're doing the
marketing things are going well
why do a test when you know that can
pretty much only result in in bad news
for them
so we're trying to introduce this as a
way to just at first test two different
creatives against each other like you're
still going to run something but why
don't we run the more effective of the
two you know creative materials
and the hope is that that's gonna get
some research design involved
um
but this is stuff we're working on now
so you know you'll have to ask me in a
year or two if this actually worked at
all or if it just ran into a dead end
thanks nate that's really helpful
frank i see you just put a question in
the chat if you want to ask that one
live
i do uh thanks rachel so um nate
i'm kind of curious is
is all the work that your teams do
one what i said one problem to one
solution
meaning uh do your stakeholder you get
with your stakeholders or your users and
say hey what's the problem you need to
solve
okay great understand the problem let's
build a solution right maybe you
maintain that maybe it's a one-time
analysis
is there anything that that you've
worked on and your teams have worked on
that
you've been able to say oh there's a
problem here here and here they have
very similar characteristics can we
build something that can serve all three
of those
groups
and
and right then you can scale a little
bit better but a lot of the problems
that i see coming to me and my team and
a lot of other data science teams are
hey here's my problem and then we do a
lot of work and we solve that problem
and then we have this thing to to
support and maintain and then we do that
a hundred times and we're like oh my
gosh we're maintaining everything
so i'm wondering if anything pops to
mind
yeah so
one certainly we have the same thing
with stakeholders where they have one
problem in mind that they want us to
solve
i do think our
our price elasticity work does does fall
into this category um so one of the
things is you know we initially insisted
on well we're going to need a bunch of
data because if we're going to
understand the effect of price we need
to simultaneously understand the effect
of other things that are going on
so as it turns out in our quest to you
know just model price elasticities we
also have a way to think about
competitive sets
like who's actually competing with you
on price we have a way to think about
distribution
um we have a way to think about you know
we've also used it for bottle size
changes
um
and then
you know one
one other issue that we have that we're
i'm trying to to solve with with
modifications of the model and this may
sound
weird although all of you are in the
industry but like defining what a
product is
is is a non-trivial task that's why i
said it would sound weird like you think
oh it's 750 milliliters of jack daniels
but if we change the design is it the
same pro like if we change the cover
just a little is it the same or
different if we pair it with a shot
glass is it the same or different well
like clearly it's different and clearly
it also is going to like take away sales
but like
you know so what do we do when it comes
to like the the gift packaging
essentially that that we model all of
the time is that a separate problem or
can we combine it in with our price
elasticity models
so what we have
we have tried to do i think in in the
spirit of this is
we really are trying to get to a place
where we have
a model of the market and it answers a
bunch of questions because it's taking a
fairly holistic view
of the market you know so it can help us
answer out of stock questions it can
help us answer questions about gift
about promotions about
about all of this and it's also
one model
uh on uh so from like zero to a hundred
percent where do you think you are where
from where you want to be
um
i'll go with
60 maybe we actually have i mean
most of this stuff works uh we still
have a bit of an issue there but you
know we are able to use it to look at
like counter factual situations look at
actual situations
you know we have gotten
fairly good adoption of let's look at
the the market this way
right on
cool thank you
thanks nate
um erifa asked a question earlier that
was how do you use different work so for
example data process collection model
building api development in your team
do you have dedicated people for certain
tasks or is it more like everyone is
doing some of everything
yeah so this is a great question because
i know it's a very ongoing debate and
like how to organize data science teams
and if we should have
have specialists and
the answer within our team is is some of
both
we do want people to be able to go
fairly end to end on data science
products and also to
to get a chance to do different things
like people stuck only developing
front-end dashboards are people who are
going to get tired of developing
front-end dashboards eventually almost
no matter how much they
they like it so we do want people to get
to rotate um probably our biggest
restriction is
you know like we've got three people on
our team who can actually push stuff to
the database so like in terms of
administration
we do have some stuff there we do have
some folks who are a bit more on the
data engineering side
and while we encourage people to develop
skills across
you know all things certainly like not
everyone is equally proficient across
our python tableau and sql
and so what you have will
will depend um on what people's skills
are and what they're trying to
develop
um
but even across the tech i mean it looks
like you're also talking about you know
process and collection model building
experimentation maintenance etc
yeah for the most part we tend to divide
that by
by business area rather than by by tech
within so like someone in production
will
actually be out at the production site
thinking about the sensors and how they
get that into the database and then
they're also going to build the model
based on the temperature data collected
from that that sensors and that doesn't
mean like
you know within the hub we have some
people who specialize more in modeling
and they're going to talk to those
people about like what's an appropriate
statistical model here but yeah they're
going to code it they're going to own it
they're going to be responsible for
usually maintaining what they build
awesome thank you i love thinking about
how like your data science team is
actually like right there where they're
making the whiskey too
um so there's a few other anonymous
questions too that came in earlier and
one was when you were talking a bit
about
marketing experiments someone said could
you please share any actual examples
of the experiments run
i would love to because i would love to
get marketing to run an actual
experiment
um
so no this is still something we're
trying to get them
so i think one of the issues here is
you know i've i've said
hey
i've worked through this data i've built
out the model and you know when i do all
reasonable things that you can do to the
data
i just don't see this effect i can't
detect it doesn't mean it's not there
per se but
um so
while i can say that internally
a consultant does not have to say that
they will tell you they can in fact see
the effect of your marketing campaign
uh i had a lengthy back and forth with
with the consultant
um asking in their their about their
methodology and
you know essentially they're overfitting
the data
um you know like they're getting there
by
well yeah by pretty blatantly over
fitting the data but then you know we're
in a situation where the consultant is
giving a report that says hey what
you're doing works and i'm giving a
report that says hey i don't know you
need better research design um
and in that situation you know you can
see where the the consultant's
messages
is a bit more appealing i i think
there's a chance we are eventually going
to get to
to some internal research design but we
are just not there yet
thank you for the openness there too
yeah zach i see you're talk asking a bit
about r and python together would uh
would you mind
asking that question live
yeah sure uh so a bit of background on
me i've only started coding in the last
well just over a year now so i focus a
lot on our uh i can build quite
efficient shiny apps and do quite a lot
in r but i've not yet expanded to python
i was just wondering as you just talked
about like python and are together
like in the same team would it benefit
me
as someone that's looking to go into
this industry
to learn python as well as are or do i
just specialize in our as much as
possible and get the skills required
there
yeah so very directly i will say
specialize in one or the other and my my
personal bias would be r unless you are
very much into machine learning and ai
but if you want to
do data work do statistics work wrangle
data and be able to present it to
stakeholders just shiny marked down deep
plier things that i don't think are
quite matched in the python ecosystem
yet
and while the python ecosystem has all
sorts of great things for you know web
scraping machine learning etc
mostly you can do both in either
language
but i do think there are still enough
differences where you know i'll call
those out as perhaps a reason to choose
one over the other
so the main reason we support both r and
python is for separate data scientists
you know on the market being able to
have data scientists and recruit data
scientists if what they know is python
or if what they know is r
we do occasionally use both
so one example is we wanted to
uh work on automating the scheduling of
the tanks that hold the liquid before
they're dumped into bottles
and it turns out that python had a
pretty good package for doing some of
that sort of automated scheduling that r
did not have
but we wanted to deliver this as a shiny
app
um and so we use the reticula package
you know so we we get the data in from
from our through the shiny app and then
we have a python function that does the
actual scheduling on the back end
returns the results through r
a lot of our python folks
have wound up learning a bit of r and
that's largely to present their final
results
because again like
we use our markdown
for reports pretty heavily we also use
shiny apps and there is a fluidity to
that
you know even for the python folks like
sure they could maybe do everything in
python and then present purely in
tableau
but it doesn't mix as well for a formal
report if you also want like the sort of
writing that you have in markdown
so so they'll dump python chunks in but
here again this is mostly because that's
what they're familiar with
um
so r is really forced by the
communication piece and
python could be forced if there's a
package you really want to use but also
just if that's what you're already
familiar with
thanks nate
thank you and just want to say awesome
zack that you just started within the
past year and you're already building
shiny apps too that's awesome
a quick question that is not data
science related nate but people ask
where did you get your chair from
where did i get my chair oh
uh i think
i ordered it on amazon at the beginning
of the pandemic when i started working
from home i decided to invest in a
comfortable chair
and the gaming chairs were a lot cheaper
than the office chairs i'm not actually
a pc gamer just by the chair but
yeah
thank you
robert i see you had asked the question
a bit earlier
can i uh turn that over to you
sure i i don't know if this question
will make any sense but it makes sense
in
my brain um it just it feels like
especially maybe during the uh pandemic
and afterwards like consumer goods
like there's just these waves of trends
that are just like totally unpredictable
that like people get really into like
very niche stuff like like japanese
whiskey and like certain handbags now
and sports cards and it's just like
totally throws off um
like consumer behavior i was just
wondering if like a does that make any
sense and b like is that something that
you think about or does that affect like
analytics
yeah so
i mean not just during the pandemic but
like bourbon boomed from like 2011
through well it's still booming um
and it's a huge question of like will
that end or like vodka had a moment in
like the zeros i guess we'd call them
right the 2000s um
especially like flavored vodka and so
forth and then it really declined after
that and so there's a huge question in
our our industry of like what those
trends will look like
and you know i did work on a project
trying to look at like the bourbon boom
and when will it end what will whiskey
look like in 10 years and you know the
spoiler alert is i don't really know
um so like those sorts of trends are
hard to predict how it affects analytics
is that a lot of our analytics is is
against that background so
you know like i'm
i'm generally not trying to predict how
the whiskey category will do i'm looking
at like how woodford and jack will do
within the whiskey category and that
actually helped a lot during the
pandemic um you know like sales were all
over the place but our model was
basically just like okay yeah this is a
reflection of the category and like it
didn't really have a problem figuring
out what what was happening with pricing
uh with the exception of a few places
where it was literally shut down
altogether like pennsylvania had a
couple of
days out of a week where they just shut
liquor stores and there was like this
huge bike right before and then
nothing after and the price stayed the
same throughout so like that sort of
thing causes a problem but
in general
we we try to do our analytics against
the background of consumer trends more
so than than trying to really figure out
consumer trends because
as you pointed out they can be triggered
by fairly random and hard to describe
processes
did you have to
um
like market certain sizes of bottles or
anything like during coping because of
supply chain issues or like not getting
certain bottles my
my neighbor works for budweiser and at
one point there were just no bottles
available
yeah um so during covid
i mean one this wasn't a supply chain
issue but folks did change to like
buying larger sizes in general
um
and then yes i mean i i'm fairly sure
it's it's pretty public that you know we
like literally every other industry have
had at least some supply chain issues
um
that i know of i don't know that we've
pushed and marketed different stuff but
i don't actually work on the
the sales team that would you know
ultimately make those the sort of last
mile decisions about like who gets what
product and
and what we market so
yeah and i apologize if i mispronouncing
your name but i see you had asked a
question
as well around time series would you
want to jump in and add any text there
i can also read
the question is
what type of programming language do you
use to be combined with r in order to be
used for loops and for time series with
pseudo time
and i may have messed up reading that so
please jump in if you want to add
anything as well
yeah so i'm not
fully aware of what what you mean by
just saying pseudotime but you know our
our time series analysis for
for forecasting um we do use r um we use
uh the stuff that's coming out of the
university of monash like the the civil
book um i learned forecasting by reading
forecasting principles and practice by
rob hindman
i was initially you know given the
question of like how much vodka will be
sold in russia next year and apparently
a whole lot was not a sufficient answer
um but like this has evolved from there
to um
you know we do
a fair amount of of testing we'll look
at you know what would an exponential
smoothing model say what would an arima
model say tried a neural net model that
almost never performed better and took a
lot of time to run so we don't usually
even test it now
we'll also do just like a seasonal naive
forecast as a baseline and then finally
we we do use facebook's profit model as
one of them and
one of the things we like about that in
some ways is the interpretability
like we we try to sell time series into
the organization as you need to
understand trend and you need to
understand seasonality
right so we're going to make you graphs
of trend and seasonality
don't worry as much about the back end
map that that's what we're going to do i
mean we're happy to you know dig people
into that but as far as explaining
things a lot of it is like look at this
noisy data over time here's what it
looks like when we strip out seasonality
and put in a trend line
here's what happens when we move the
trend line forward and then we put back
in the seasonality
um
and even just doing that i think has has
actually been helpful for the business
and and thinking about what's going to
happen next year
stevie i see you've unmuted and i just
want to take that as you raising your
hand do you have a question
oh sorry i just uh put the question in
the other thing but that's fine oh yeah
uh
so how do you cope uh
as a data user also there's people
presumably looking after your big server
which is who are doing
our updates and major upgrades to our
studio how do you cope with that or do
you
do you let them change the system or
do you have some way of parallel running
what's your
what's your relationship with your
scissor bins i'm speaking this has just
happened
oh we've got a guy who is you know
supposed to be running sap but did a lot
of work with linux servers in college
and was willing to to help us so we have
a part-time sysadmin who runs all of our
stuff um
you know like we we work together pretty
closely he's always very helpful
we probably do not have everything
locked down as well as we potentially
should
um
you know we
a couple weeks ago ran into an issue
where
um with our versions between like 3.6
and 4.0 where there's miscommunication
about like should we be running it on
which one um
i i briefly mentioned like one reason we
want to switch our production work to
our studio connect instead of our studio
workbench is because connect is going to
by default produce an isolated
environment
and it's going to give the user a lot
more control
over what's in that environment
so
you know within workbench like yes we
can use tools like rm as a user to like
have our own libraries have our own
systems within there
but there is also a base library and
right now like that base
library is what's used by the automated
jobs
and so we we need all of our automated
jobs to be able to run on the same set
of packages right now so there's a
reason we're going to change away from
that as the number of automated jobs
increases
but generally yeah we just have a really
helpful sys admin who's doing this as
part of his job and we could not do it
without him so
so yes thank you on on behalf of uh
whoever your uh your data scientists are
we appreciate sis admins
love that so
taking that a bit further then if
somebody is within their team trying to
find who
should be managing
that tool set or like communicating with
sysadmins
steve or nate do you have any any advice
for
for those listening in
so i'll i'll do what we're trying to uh
trying to do we try we have a teams
microsoft teams channels where we're
actually managing that
so we'll have a whole group where we'll
do announcement messages on about major
services and things
but then we'll have a support group
where people will ask questions and
we'll provide have that as a mix
rather than a ticketing system which is
sort of
you know private between the person
raising the tickets and the issue what
we're trying to do is try and get people
to publicly ask their questions
usually in the hope that somebody else
will answer the question for us
and this thus offload the work of us
but we'll also probably have uh you know
within within teams again we'll have a
like a little management channel where
we talk discuss
you know
do we really want to install this new
version of our or what do we do about uh
versions of libraries which are
incompatible
with what uh so some of you wanting a
new version of proj or gdal
which just isn't supported on our base
operating system that creates all sorts
of
fun and difficulties we're going to work
out how to scale or to swap over so
having having a lot of communication
with users to and the administrators
just to try and make sure that there is
as much communication as possible so
that when people ask for something weird
and exotic
when we actually turn around and say
well now we can't really do that because
that's gonna be that's gonna take
involve a lot of work which is only and
you're the only person that's probably
affected
people can see transparently why we've
made the decisions
not to help them
so it's it's a it's a challenge
communication is the main thing
and also forever what we're trying to do
is look forever at our infrastructure
and say
have we got the right sort of uh mix of
machines and we're currently looking at
migrating over to the cloud and
uh more automation for building our
studio so using terraform and ansible
and trying to work out how to do all
that so
it's a continuous
journey yeah that answer
makes me happy because it's the same um
google instead of microsoft but yeah we
have like a server use channel and that
is how we
coordinate with our
our team and our sys edmond
that's great thank you i know we're just
at the top of the hour here do you have
time for one more question nate you have
to run okay awesome shannon i see you
had asked a question a little bit
earlier do you want to ask that one live
i could also or shannon maybe had to
drop but
um the question was do you ever go back
to evaluate your predictions or
forecasts to actuals
yes we do um we do that pretty
consistently
our our most formal process for that
launched in like may so that that
doesn't have a ton but when we build out
our forecasting in the first place we go
back and
um
you know look what would this method
have forecasted if we had done it you
know 10 years ago
roll forward a window a year or so
and if you look at like the forecasting
principles in practice i see someone has
has dropped a link there also no there's
a third edition um you just need to
change the two at the end two of three
um and
you know it talks about how you can
essentially cross-validate your your
forecast by rolling through what it
would have been and we've also compared
it to like the forecast that uh internal
teams made
um we were able to get a hold of some of
those and compare like the model
forecast to the human forecast as well
great thank you so aside from that
forecasting principles book are there
other resources you'd recommend we take
a look at
i like you know reading our weekly and
data elixir as newsletters um of course
the rstudio blog to keep up with some of
the new open source stuff that's
coming out there um i think so many of
my
my actual recommendations though would
be
you know scattered of like what would i
recommend to a new user what would i
recommend for forecasting what would i
recommend for causal inference or price
elasticities etc so
yeah
that makes sense well thank you so much
nate i think we've answered
all the questions from everyone unless
there's anything i miss please stop me
now
thank you so much for for sharing your
insights with us and answering
everybody's questions
um the last thing i'd just like to ask
if anybody had follow-up questions for
you what's the best way to get in touch
is it linkedin or twitter
uh probably twitter i guess um
i can just put my handle and then the
chat that works perfect
well thank you so much nate really
appreciate it and have a great rest of
the day everyone
you